Hello, Champions.  We will now begin the
Chesley
Morning Brief for Thursday, July 2nd, bringing you happy investment plans
.  Let's find out
how China wrapped up the first day of July with Director Wang
.   yes
.  Yesterday, cyclical
stocks rose by 2.44%.   The
Hong Kong market is Hyojeong.
Um, uh, if it's
regular admission, it has risen to 3.7 trillion
.  If you are narrowing down by industry, I learned that the
Teskir finance and real estate sectors are strong,
whereas the communication and IT
sectors are weak.  Financial stocks are showing a rebound due
to rising trading volume and expectations for agency services
.  Merit
Enhancement increased by 5% for Double, Eastern
Treasure by 5%, Ancient Haedong by 5%, and Lifetime
Strength by 3%.
The categories also grew together.  China Acquisition
Law reached 9.7%, Zhonggu 3.8%, and Xinhua
Law nearly hit the upper limit.
Oh, regarding consumer goods, the capital is also half the price.  His
time.  0.7% for 6% blue-chip.
Healthcare-
related stocks also rose yesterday due to an influx of buying stimulus.  The oath
limit was 3.3%, 1% was 4%, and
0.6%.  Yesterday, early on,
your semiconductor was really good.  The latter half went
down a little.   There were probably a
few things that were given to Zen monks
.  Semiconductor equipment stocks have
risen quite strongly.  How about the Northern Fire? It
went up an additional 5.7%.   I
filed a report on that history.  The ratio of Youngso has
risen by about 104%.  This time,
Langi Tech rose by 1.9%, Jeon Tech by 3%,
and the lower layer by 2.4%
.
Yesterday, major global MLC manufacturers
raised prices as planned.
Following this news, MLC-related stocks are
rising.  Hwa's capital increase rose to 2%, and
Hwaseong Tech rolled to 3%.
Airlines also
showed strength due to yoga, etc.  China
Eastern Airlines is listed at 3%.  The
second-quarter earnings reports for major companies
were released yesterday.  So, Taebae Kwon Yong-jo
came up yesterday.  Cheonbeon Holdings
rose by 3%, but Untong Taebae came out at 10%,
Sintong Taebae at 10%, and Yundal Taebae
at 8%.  On the other hand, PCB
optical communication government stocks have all been removed.
Approval Tech fell to -5%, while the stock showing improvement
dropped to -5%.  The new salt reserve
interest rate rose by 1.3bp.   The
silver price rate rose by 2bp,
and the foreign exchange rate
was reduced to around 0.5%.
thank you  Uh, listening to you all this, although
I haven't looked closely at the Chinese market, it appears that the
overall characteristics were similar to the Korean market. There are
two reasons for this.
First, uh, regarding Korea as well yesterday, overall, how should I put it
?  Should I describe it as the expansion of product categories
?  As the leadership of market leaders, who had been heavily focused on semiconductors, began to
falter, buying interest shifted
to stocks that had previously declined significantly. In the
case of the Korean market yesterday, since the stock market fell, there were
n't many right stocks; however, in terms of relative performance compared to the index, there were actually more
sectors and stocks that outperformed semiconductors.  That
thought crosses my mind. Listening to what was said earlier, sectors like
healthcare, finance, and
real estate were
industries that took a break when semiconductors or IT were rising. Since you mentioned that these areas performed relatively
well, I
thought they might have been similar.
Secondly,
regarding Korea, only Samsung Electro-Mechanics surged yesterday, right? I also
think the characteristics of stocks related to printed circuit boards (PCBs) and MLCCs were somewhat similar. Is
my understanding correct? Yes, that is correct
.  Yesterday, we
had one of the indicators from Contejuro that I check every day.  Yesterday, I saw the market for car washes to be a bit
weak
.  Because, as for common sense, if it
goes below 44%, the first 2%
dropped, right?  [Clears throat]
So, it became established.  The other Zen
master, Jeong Mu-su, climbed much higher than the previous day
.
yes.  And if you look at it from a 52-year perspective, it is all
Eti.   hmm.   yes
.  The stock price isn't falling.  Almost nothing remains of
history, simply by being omitted from Jeongjong
.   hmm.
Normally, when market-
leading stocks overheat too steeply like this, the trend spreads to surrounding stocks, and once that phase settles to some extent, the
market-leading stocks rise again
. So, in Dr. Wang's model, please let us know when it is time to focus on market-leading stocks again.
[Laughs]
Understood.   yes
.  Yesterday, regarding courier companies...
the start of the courier industry... I mentioned that there were some announcement figures, and it
seems the stock you prepared is like that as well. Yes, Wan Dong Tae
Bae went up 10% yesterday, hitting the upper limit
.  It also appears in actual matches.
Hey, Holsa
is 12 trillion won right now.  It's not very big.
Ford Pian is eight times the level.  We maintained a
125% market share in the heavy-duty delivery market with two rounds
.  Oh, we're announcing preliminary results
.  Earnings for the first half are
expected to increase by 85.7% from the beginning.  If
you do the reverse line, the second quarter's ranked agreement.   It
is 2% to 89.2% or more than 2% points.  So,
based on the fixed price, it exceeded the construction cost by about 12%
.  We achieved a real-world victory through an increase in delivery volume, a
sharp rebound in ASP, and strengthened cost management
.
From January to May, the total number of fish shipments in China's Taibai industry
increased by 5.2% year-on-year, but the number of delivery
inspections increased by 7% to 9.7%.
So, it generates a higher profit margin than at that point in time
.
In particular, the ASP growth rate is being calculated continuously up to the original 2nd quarter rather than the 2nd quarter
.  I agree to the second quarter of retirement age.  3% for the
3rd quarter - 2.4% for the 4th quarter -
1.5%. Originally, if you consider the 1st quarter fingerprint from January
to May, the Pros transitioned to 0.1%
.   For
the second unit, the
ranking per pedal gun inspection increased by about 22.7% compared to the previous unit and
80% compared to the same period.   It
reached a record high once in 2022.
Okay, here are some reports on the fire scene.
Based on the current ASP further rise and the expansion of the market front, the actual trend is
expected to be an uptrend index.  Maintaining a buy position,
next year's EPS is estimated at
around 1.9, 2.1, and 2.4 respectively, and
compared to the same period, it could increase
by approximately 51.2%, 14.7%, 14.7%, 7%, and 10%
.  Taken
applied a 13x PR this year, so the TP
was 24.8.   It could
fall another 58% compared to yesterday's closing price.   yes
.  thank you  The delivery industry
isn't an industry we see often, but that's true.
[Snoring]
Uh, I’d like to make a comparison with Korea
.  In the case of Korea, the courier
industry
consists of about three, four, or five entities, including the public service delivery known as the Post Office Courier, as well as Daehan Telecom and others. I don't
know the details, but based on cash flow—that is,
EBITDA—I
understand that they are formed by consistently generating profits, albeit at a low level. I am
curious about the situation in China as well, and if... yes.
So, [sniff] if it is a situation where a few
companies are sharing the profits and
maintaining such low margins,
the companies are making a decent profit, but
[sniff] from a stock price perspective, the
question does arise as to whether we should pay attention. I am
curious about the purpose of your introduction today. This
cylindrical Taebae is smoking Hanjin Taebae, which is located somewhat in the military
.   yes
.  In the past few years,
after the COVID period passed, this industry
became evenly distributed.  So, The
Solo happened to be in the black,
so it didn't go down to a deficit, but it
dropped to almost the BP level.
So yes, that's right.  Many companies are gradually becoming unavailable,
but well, regarding
the information on invitations for 2024 and 2025, they changed the policy.
They told us not to do things like extraordinary gifts,
so from the
second retirement period onwards, we fought back and kept increasing our after-sales service
.   The
fingerprint effect is probably starting to show
. Hmm, regarding the
second and third quarters, or the fourth quarters, I think there is a possibility of
additional ASP calculations in this area
.  Because the
supply has already... well, already
become natural.  I think the
ASP price could rise slightly depending on demand recovery, and
these companies, in particular, are very
susceptible to seasonal factors.  Based on the statistics, the general trend is that
these delivery companies always have very
good stock price returns in the third quarter.
So, if you want to buy it, it seems like the temple you live in now
.  hmm.   uh
.  uh.  Yesterday, someone mentioned stocks
.
Stocks that cannot be purchased as a large portion of an investment.  yes.  I heard that stocks bought with a light trading concept are
referred to as "snacks."   So,
this is an
industry or stock that can be viewed somewhat as a trading concept
.
Would that be enough to understand?
Yes, that is correct.  Please be careful.
[Laughs]
Yes.  All right.  If you have a high cash ratio but
can't find any stocks worth buying,
let's take a look at these kinds of stocks.  I will proceed
with the stock you introduced in that context
.   yes
.  Let's look at the US market from yesterday.   I
saw on the news this morning that the
atmosphere seemed a bit bad, so let's find out what was on the story with
our Pro Yuri
.   yes
.  Uh, as you mentioned,
I've been
looking at my phone since around 9 or 10 yesterday, and there was a big
issue.  I assume
everyone has been paying attention to Meta,
so today I would like to focus my explanation on keywords
such as Meta, AI, and learning. I
also
understand that the Vice President will provide a more specific analysis of related concepts and forms later on.   yes
.  yes.   yes
.  So, first of all, if you look at the US market in terms of the index
itself, it did
close with a slight correction.
However, as memory and
semiconductor equipment stocks fell together internally, it
seems you could view today as a day when a crack appeared in the AI ​​infrastructure rally, which had been the keyword leading the overall market sentiment.   If
you look at the indices first, all major indices closed lower
.  SP
hit a 52-week high during trading.   As
the session neared its end,
profit-taking in semiconductor and infrastructure-related stocks
intensified, causing them to close with a slight decline
.  Although it
recorded an intraday high, it effectively
closed higher, while the Nasdaq closed the
sharpest, declining slightly due to weakness in the semiconductor sector.  However, as I
mentioned earlier, today was a day where internal trends were much more important than the index itself. If
you look at the macro environment first and go down to the top of this review, the
stock market was
n't actually in a bad state.  I have
always checked oil prices first, and if we look at oil prices now, although I did not
have a chart today,
WTI has
dropped to the $68 range, showing a trend where the risk premium for the Middle East seems to be less of a
concern.
Additionally, the ISM manufacturing data released during the trading session did
not place a significant burden on the market.  Now, the June
ISM manufacturing PMI has been released, and
at 53.3, it stands at 3,
continuing the expansion phase for six consecutive months.
You can refer to the text at the bottom. Since a PMI
above 50
is an indicator of economic expansion, the indicator
showed a trend of easing cost pressures as the input price index fell significantly at the same time.  So,
growth was holding up and inflationary pressures were easing, creating a
somewhat favorable environment for the stock market again.   There
were also some supplementary employment indicators released, but the indicators themselves did
not signal a sudden cooling of the stock market.  ADP private employment
increased by 98,000 in June,
falling slightly below the consensus, but the
Challenger growth rate has decreased significantly compared to the previous day
.  So, while it is difficult to say that the solid phase has strengthened again, the trend also makes it
difficult to view it as escalating into a rapid layoff cycle; therefore,
overall, it was closer to a gradual slowdown
.  Also, on the other hand, the
part that stood out a bit was the
sofa gold
part that I highlighted.  In the short-term money market, the
SOFA and IRB spread has
moved slightly toward the positive side to 3BP.  So,
SOFA is
the cost of borrowing cash for one day using government bonds as collateral, and IRB
is the interest rate the Federal Reserve pays to banks for reserves.  Therefore, the fact that the SOFA
rate is somewhat volatile implies that there was strong
demand for short-term cash funding in the reference market. Thus,
the
3-bit/3-bit figures appear to be at a level closer to technical pressure, akin to quarter-end balance sheet management and
leverage position adjustments. So,
the conclusion is
that the figures do not appear to be a signal of liquidity stress. That is
how the figures
were interpreted, and on top of that,
Wash gave an
interview and made remarks at a Sintra forum yesterday.
So,
Chairman Wash's remarks that came out here were not a significant burden on the market either
.  While Wash
clearly stated that prices remain high and he would not abandon the 2% inflation target, his
recent comments regarding inflation risks suggest that the
risks have decreased. It
seems we can interpret his remarks as not having made any statements that would completely heighten tension in the market.  So, while it is difficult to interpret this statement itself as a
signal for an interest rate cut,
at least from the
perspective of the stock market, it
seems reasonable to view it as inflation not being at a completely uncontrollable level again.
Overall, if you wrap up all these indicators and look
solely at the macroeconomics,
today's market was not significantly unfavorable for stocks
.  Well, oil prices have fallen, the
manufacturing sector has announced expansion, employment
has slowed moderately, and the
pressure on the short-term money market has
remained at a temporary level.
However, if we
consider why the index fell, it seems we can conclude that it was
n't due to macros, but rather an issue with the keyword "AI L-ri
."  So now, I would like to
tell you about Meta, who was the main character.   Now, regarding the
important point, while the stocks
rose by 8.8% yesterday, the
stocks that simultaneously fell significantly while hovering at the opposite end of the spectrum were the
aforementioned Coreweave and Nevius, which are
NeoCloud operators.
So, what is clearly evident in these indicators is not
that Meta has taken over the ministry structures of Cobi and Navi, but
rather
that infrastructure has become important, and
within that, computing equipment has been fully sold.
Therefore, it seems important to interpret what kind of moves this might show in the Big Tech sector in the future.
So, if we consider why Meta's stock price
rose, I
believe the market reacted because Meta demonstrated that there is additional upside related to its cloud business
.  But the important thing here is
that Meta is running a cloud business
.  So, rather than saying that it will make more money in the future, I
think we need to look at this from an investment perspective by dividing it into two parts. The
first is compute
sales. Raw compute refers to raw
computing equipment infrastructure, and
this is a method of renting out GPU server capacity itself
to external parties.
So, simply put, this means
renting out AI computing servers to external parties. In this
case, Meta is structured to compete
directly with NeoCloud services like CoreEve or Nevius
.  So, since
NeoCloud has been
generating revenue by renting out GPU infrastructure necessary for AI training and output,
regarding this aspect,
Meta is going to provide a
service that rents out our GPUs going forward
.  If they say that Coip Navius ​​is
no longer needed, it means they are now
competing directly with them, and I
think that has been primarily reflected in the stock price.  However, moving on to the second point,
there is another method where Meta sells access rights to the infrastructure where the models are hosted. In this case, the
structure is such that users do not download and run the models directly, but rather access and use models running on the Meta infrastructure.  So, you can think of this as being
somewhat similar to Amazon's AWS Bedrock. It is
similar to the method of calling AI models within the cloud, just like AWS Bedrock.  I mentioned those somewhat complex words, but if you
break them down and think about them, you can just
look at the image on the right
.  I also
tried simplifying the image using Claude. If
you look at the image, the left side is training and the
right side is inference.  In the
case of learning, it is the stage of building a model.  So,
within this, a large-scale GPU cluster
is needed, and
high-performance GPUs like the H100, H200, B200, and GB200
are important stages.
And now, if you move to the right side, the situation is
similar there as well, but the
key point is which 9th-generation infrastructure is being
disposed of and which
new infrastructure is being introduced. You should pay close attention to this. What is
important here is that the core issue seems to be which computing infrastructure Meta said it would dispose of—that is, as it announced it would
sell off its assets while entering the cloud market
.  However,
if they intend to move
forward to the inference stage by selling 9th-generation infrastructure, then the
cloud revenue
itself could be justified. But if,
instead, the
structure becomes one where they carry everything and expand to include inference infrastructure, it could be interpreted as meaning that
their current business model is
not profitable and they need to expand in a new direction
. Therefore, I believe the key question here will be specifically what kind of infrastructure they plan to sell in the future.  no see.  And if they
decide not to sell the existing infrastructure and continue to keep it, it could
become a direct competitive burden for NeoCloud.  However,
putting that aside, to determine whether such upside in metal stock prices can continue in the future, the key issues seem to be whether
it is based on learning,
inference, or if
there is definitely more upside, and beyond that, whether this could have an
impact on the big tech sector
.   yes
.  So, if you look at the Big Tech sector as well, it did
show a relatively strong trend.  While Meta was the strongest,
Microsoft rose 3%, and
Apple also increased—meaning Amazon and
Google also
recorded gains.
Rather than simply being risk-free, you could view this as a trend where platform companies capable of handling AI infrastructure investments, generating
cloud
revenue, and
commercializing infrastructure were valued at a
premium
.  Conversely, if you look further down, the sector that was primarily
perceived as a burden on the market was
semiconductors.  Micron
has now fallen by about 10%, and SanDisk has also now
fallen by about 10%.  However, the
trend of memory and semiconductor equipment stocks falling together
seems important.
Rather than focusing on the price aspect—which is frequently discussed in the market these days—such as memory prices rising significantly, the fact that equipment stocks have dropped together suggests that the
AI ​​value chain itself has begun to face challenges. You can view this as a primary trend indicating that the AI ​​value chain itself has
started to face challenges
.  However,
the point you need to keep in mind when making future investments is that there is a
decline in the semiconductor market.  So,
rather than saying that A-number has collapsed, I think it is necessary to track the future products and roadmaps announced by these companies to see
what kind of computational dimensions this meta will sell in the future and which
areas will
generate revenue for the big tech sector
.
Conversely, if you look at the healthcare sector, you
could say that it was a market where the two siblings were somewhat scattered.
I diversified my portfolio across several stocks today, and
there were new highs in financial stocks, healthcare, and the trend
showed a spread to the materials sector as well.  So, as I
mentioned earlier regarding macroeconomics, the
stock market itself was favorable; however, I would like to
point out that it
is worth noting that there was pressure for profit-taking in AI, semiconductor, memory, and equipment stocks, as they had risen significantly.  So, I have shared a lot of things today, but to
summarize the key points of today's market,
I think we are now at a point where the questions regarding the market in the second half of the year are shifting
.  So,
I was actually a bit more curious today about why they chose this particular timing for the announcement
.  Although the
department head will likely explain this later,
starting from the second half of the year, we have begun to see more clearly whether this infrastructure is being
recovered as actual revenue
.  If we had simply divided
companies into those that make money and those that spend money, you could say that the
question has now shifted to whether a company can truly make money even within the profit-making sector. You could also view this as
Meta becoming a
starting point that poses new questions regarding the AI ​​infrastructure rally as it begins the second half of the year
.   That's
all.   hmm.   yes
.  He gave a long speech, and when I
checked this morning, Meta's stock price had risen by more than 8%
.  And Micron dropped more than 10%
.  I had just
looked at some headlines, and my initial thought was quite simplistic: were
companies investing in data center AI to generate revenue moving towards using less memory, driven by
new ideas or strategic
directions centered around metal? However, after
listening to Yuripro, my perspective has
shifted slightly. I think that as
companies that need to make money through investment—that is, by spending money to generate revenue—emerge with clear directions or concrete roadmaps for how they will make money in the second half of the year,
interest might broaden beyond just hardware-related
stocks. Is that
correct?  I
thought so.  Because, actually, while
changes in a company's business models are
always an issue for that specific company, when
looking at how that direction will ultimately lead to investment, my initial
judgment was whether we
should focus more on making money again.  I
thought that the Yomenta issue might have been the catalyst for a shift in the fundamental question of whether we should now be looking more at the segment of beauty pageants in terms of making money
.  yes.  Since this is intertwined with the market, the
market may have reacted a bit more sensitively on a
one-day basis, but
we will
continue to follow the news to see how it looks and also monitor
whether portfolio changes are necessary
.
Thank you for summarizing it clearly again today.  Let's move on to virtual assets
.  Assistant Manager Junhyeok,
virtual assets have been sluggish, so I am
curious to know what news there was yesterday.  yes.   I will
tell you the truth.
Amidst the sluggish trend, the price movement was
decent yesterday.  I think we can just look at the main points of Kevin's speech yesterday
.  Not only K-Venusi, but also the personnel determining interest rates
at the European central bank in 22 have
eased inflation and inflationary pressure has somewhat
subsided.  And Kevin Assi also said the
risk of inflation has come down a little.
And, with remarks indicating that inflation expectations have been falling for four consecutive weeks, and
showing a trend moving away from interest rate hikes,
Bitcoin prices rose once again.
And
since it also reflects the trend of stock prices reacting sensitively to interest rates, you can view this as the price
showing a short-term reaction
.  yes.  If
you look at the long-term Bitcoin chart on the right, you can
see that it has recovered to about $60,000
.  The
200-week moving average is around 6 dollars.  However, I
mentioned last time that in a cycle, the price always falls slightly below the 200-week moving average, finds a bottom there, and then rises again; I
think I can say that level will likely be around $62,000.
If you look at the Bitcoin Fred Index, the extreme fear zone is
recording around 11.  Uh, regarding the
outflows of spot ETFs by ranking, if
you look at the right side here, it is all red
, to the extent that the outflows are
continuing.  So, it is said that
spot ETFs have been
recording net outflows for about 7 consecutive weeks, and as of
June 30, you
can view it as an outflow of approximately 222 million.
There is something I briefly mentioned yesterday, and uh, if you look at the main section,
I titled it "Is the Era of Circles Over?"
Uh,
there is a consortium exam called Open Standard on June 30th (July 1st Korean time), and
140 companies
are participating.  They unveiled a dollar-pegged
stablecoin called US Open USD, or
5 USD.   It is
not actually being commercialized right now, but you can view it as being closer to a
consortium-style announcement that they intend to do this.
Coinbase, Visa, Mastercard,
Google, and others participated, and domestic companies
included Samsung Electronics, Hyundai Motor, and Kakao
.  Uh, I think
we should keep an eye on Coinbase.
Coinbase has been operating under a structure where it participates in USC—that is,
Circle's—business model and
receives a share of the fees and profits from it,
but
now Coinbase is participating in other stablecoins.  With
news like this coming out, while Point
Base
could certainly be straddling both sides, seeing that they bet on one side as well as the
other, the concern that
Circle's valuation
premium might be slightly reduced is very
strong. Therefore, you can view yesterday's
stock price as having dropped by about 16% to 17%
.  So, regarding
what Open Standard is trying to introduce,
there is an article introducing Open USD.  STEPPIN is being rapidly adopted
due to its speed, cost, and programmability, and it is
said that there is an automated payment network called ACH in the US.  It approaches the network there.
However, companies still face significant barriers.
Most sable
coins have exorbitant issuance and redemption fees for
large-scale transactions.
Furthermore, companies are not always guaranteed a share of the
profits generated from issuing funds from their reserves or
investing in short-term government bonds.
Developers also state that there are few alternatives available even if the roadmaps of third-party issuers
fail to meet their requirements
.  So, Open
says it has introduced three core design principles, and what is called Bill Scale is that, as I
mentioned earlier, there are
absolutely no issuance or redemption fees.
Therefore, companies can issue and redeem open bonds without incurring costs or
artificial restrictions on trading volume
.
And regarding the second point, which states "unarned by
default," it says that
partners will receive the
full amount of reserve fund profits, excluding a small management fee to cover Open's operating costs.
Thirdly, it
states that they will manage it together through collaboration. The
Open USD independent entity will be
operated by Open Standard, and it is
composed of Open USD partners to
ensure that decision-making is made for the common good rather than by a single entity. You can
view this as the console test announcing that we have introduced these three points—things that Circle has not been able to do—as core design principles. The
Chairman and CEO of Open Standard, mentioned earlier, was the
CEO of Stripe, the payment system and stablecoin payment network.   You can
consider it as the CEO having now created Open Standard Open USD
.  Since this is not actually becoming a reality yet, the trend is
now moving toward
gradually taking market share from the Stiblecoin market, and it does
not seem to have been definitively decided yet which network—whether it be Ethereum or Solana—or which chain it will operate on
.  They initially stated that they would have Solana work with them, but it
seems nothing has been definitively decided yet.   If
you look at the photo at the bottom left, there are about
140 participating companies.
There are domestic companies, and there are also a
great many overseas companies.  You could
say that the fact that there is almost a Coinbase is very impressive, and if you look to the right to see how the current Stable
coin market is, it is about
311 billion.  So, I've only
included the logos of the two most important players. The
blue section on the right is the Tether
part, and Tether currently takes up about 60% of the space
.  The
circle we know of accounts for about 24% of USDC
.  Ultimately,
even if Open 5 USD is released, the
future
valuation will depend on how much market share can be captured in this market, but determining exactly how much can be taken is
actually a somewhat uncertain
aspect.
Uh, please scroll down a bit, and I think I
can give you a brief explanation along with some photos
.  Uh, USDT,
I’ve included the reaction to the 1st place modification I just mentioned, and
uh, welcome.  Let's try
this together.
You can consider this as a kind of reaction, and
USDC’s Jeremy Allian
wrote a rather impressive letter.
So, there was an explanation as to why this consortium has a high
probability of failure, and
in what aspects the parts we previously
mentioned as problems with this business model—specifically
oUSD—are
not actually problems
.  So, I explained earlier about the
part about issuing for free and then repaying, but they say that if
repayments keep coming in due to cost issues,
it becomes
unmanageable.  So, they
accurately refuted those parts.
Regarding the return of all profits, it is said that if
all profits are given away to partners, it
actually leads to the effect of weakening the infrastructure, which is difficult to maintain the system stably or
develop it for security purposes
.
So, I am saying that a consortium model where profits are all divided up like this
can have significant disadvantages and some
limitations.
Thirdly, regarding joint governance—
this might be a bit of a metaphorical expression—you know how there is a
saying that "too many cooks spoil the broth"?  So, of course, it’s
not like all 140 companies each said a word and got a bill, but ultimately, there have been several attempts like this
.  Let's get together with about 30 companies and try
creating a stablecoin
.  There have been several projects like this, but they ended
in failure
.  He gave analogies to those things and
remarked that participating in governance jointly in that way could also be somewhat limited and have its boundaries.  Uh, among those, there is
something I mentioned yesterday.
If you look at the part highlighted in yellow, it
says "Network Effect."
Ultimately, having already secured a dominant position, the network
effect and the
community established here inevitably give us an
overwhelming advantage in the market. For
example, if
we are currently using Won, but
suddenly someone tells us to use something other than Won, that is
.  If you tell people to spend 5 won, I think there is a
high probability that older people or those of that nature will feel a strong sense of resistance. I believe there are times when I just set it down
intentionally
.  Oh, actually, I
think the USDC stablecoin is also very similar.  While that
might be beneficial from a company's perspective—seeing it as a way to
share profits—
ultimately,
since the actual users aren't sharing the revenue, I
think the places where it's actually used might wonder, "What is that?"  So,
considering such network effects, it
seems that stablecoins might not be able to cause significant tectonic shifts in the market I mentioned earlier.  And even
if there are tectonic shifts, we should proceed while keeping in mind that
as the stablecoin market grows, the profits that A Coin Circle will continue to
earn can gradually increase
.  And regarding what I mentioned earlier about
the network not being definitively set, those are the
two facts at the very bottom.
So, Solana said at first, "I will
do it together."  It proceeded with the plan to work together with Open USD, but
I previously explained that the
reason Ethereum is bound to be the winner is that the
value of the chain running on top of Ethereum is much greater. Therefore,
when considering complementary value or a complementary perspective, doing it on Ethereum is
inevitably safer
.  So,
looking at the chain breakdown on the right,
out of the 311 billion stablecoins mentioned earlier,
Ethereum currently
accounts for nearly 50% of the stablecoin market
.  And then is second place
Solar?  Solana is not second place.
Solana is a single-digit figure of 4.8%.   It
accounts for about 29% of the chain called Tron
.  So, I think I can briefly explain that choosing Solana and
going into it could be a somewhat risky choice, given the determination of those
larger corporations to seize market dominance, as
opposed to choosing Ethereum
.  I
think it is correct to assume that doing it at a large venue is always advantageous.
So, if we look at the wrap-up, it
appears that the consortium was launched with the intention of taking over the stablecoin market, with various companies participating. However, I believe the true
significance of that launch lies
not in actually seizing the stablecoin market, but in the
project itself; I
think it is a project well-suited for straddling two sides.  So, we will
distribute all the reserve fund profits shown here as well.  In this regard, regarding
Coinbase and
domestic companies, it appears to me currently in a somewhat fragmented way that the consortium was
launched and Stecoin
was released not because they thought it would actually work, but because they reviewed the consortium's intentions from various angles and thought it was worth investing in
.  So,
unless it was the actual value of the circle itself, the big picture itself was
n't damaged that much.  And considering that the
stablecoin market as a whole is expected to
grow to about the dollar level in two years, I
think I can say that the overall picture hasn't really been damaged.   That's
all.
Thank you. Over the past few days, it seems like our Chief Junyeok has been focusing less on
analyzing the prices of virtual assets themselves and more on explaining the
crises facing companies involved, how they are
consolidating, and
how regulatory frameworks are changing
.  Ah, I
think it helps a lot to understand this industry in a broad sense.  I will continue to study
.  We will end Part 1 here
.
Thank you to everyone who joined us.   We will
see you in Part 2 shortly with more details.  thank you
[Music]
Hello, Choi Milton members.  This is Part 2 of the
Chesley Morning Brief, sharing happy investment moments, on
Thursday, July 2nd.
Mr. Jeom is currently in an external Zoom seminar, so I will
proceed for a moment at the beginning and then
switch with him when he returns
.  Uh, I
received a briefing on the US market, which is a bit gloomy. It’s just a
bit down because investments are centered on semiconductors, not because the market has
collapsed or the macroeconomic outlook has shifted
.  I will
hear the details from our Vice President.
yes.
First of all, if you look at the index, it just ended up as
Dow or SMP
2,000, roughly according to the abbreviation.  But the Philippine
index fell by 6%.
So yesterday
I mentioned 101, or something like that, but now it is
at 88.5. If you
look at it from 100, it says that it has
dropped by about 12% in simple terms
.  So it dropped 6%, but why does it
look like it dropped 12%?  It might look like this
[clears throat], but since the
reference point is different, if you go
from 100 to 200 and then drop 6%, it means
10 is lost, right?  So, in the end, it
reached 88%, but anyway, that is the situation
.  It was a
day when the semiconductor sector took a significant hit, and at the same time, regarding the
overall rotation—as I
briefly discussed with the CEO yesterday—it
seems like it was a day where broadening occurred and sector expansion took place.
Looking at the macroeconomics, interest rates—based on the
10-year yield—were 1.42
% and 4.48%, and oil prices fell, so there
wasn't much change.
Also, the S&ISM manufacturing PMI
came out well, although slightly lower than the market consensus. However,
one piece of news acted to weaken overall semiconductor
sentiment
.  As Yuripro
mentioned, it was related to Meta, but let's
look at that later. First, if we
look at the June ISM Manufacturing PMI, it
actually came out at 53.3, which is
a bit lower than the consensus of 53.9 and the previous 54.
And if you look at the details, new
orders, production, and supplier deliveries have
decreased somewhat.
And ah, employment indicators will be released today. Regarding
employment,
within the ISM Manufacturing PMI,
May increased by 7 from 48.6 to 49.7
.  Prices
dropped sharply from 82.1 in May to 73 in June.
It seems that the drop in oil prices itself has affected inflation.   The
ISM reports that among the six largest manufacturing sectors, all except coal and oil recorded expansion.  In terms of expansion
strength, it was said that the rankings were computers and electronic products,
machinery and transportation equipment, chemical products,
food and beverages, and tobacco
.  So, it is a
goodinvestment in the IT, machinery, and transportation equipment sectors.   While
there are some survey responses with slightly different nuances, for your reference,
regarding chemical products, it was stated that the conflict in Iran affected all commodity prices, and
items with a high proportion of oil in their raw material composition, such as adhesives, were significantly impacted. On the other hand,
regarding computers and electronics, it was mentioned that a more conservative approach to CAPEX is being taken due to the ongoing conflict in the Middle East,
although purchases of consumables and services are increasing
.  They commented that the
retail sales of electronic products in the electrical equipment and home appliance parts sector are
considered to be somewhat stable
.   In the
food, beverage, and tobacco sectors,
the cost of key raw materials remains high due to the Middle East conflict and tariff uncertainty,
and efforts are being made to simultaneously secure
cost stability and operational flexibility by diversifying suppliers and adjusting contract structures
.
And regarding machinery, you
mentioned that there is very strong demand for equipment supporting the defense industry and semiconductor manufacturing. This seems to align with the
strong stock price momentum recently seen in the semiconductor equipment sector
.  Regarding guitar
manufacturing, they stated that the core business remains solid despite geopolitical uncertainties
.
As the likelihood of the end of the Japan-Korea war increases, the recent
rise in oil and coal prices is expected to normalize.
New tariffs on transportation equipment
continue to undermine profitability and demand, leaving companies with
no choice but to raise prices to absorb the tax burden.  So, generally speaking,
although it varies somewhat depending on the type of business, I
think they made a comment about Pyongyang.
The fact that there is very strong demand for semiconductor manufacturing-related machinery in the machinery sector.  And
the fact that oil price increases are expected to normalize in the coal and petroleum product sectors.  Uh,
these parts were interpreted as positive comments
.
Uh, Meta's entry into the cloud business
shifted overall semiconductor sentiment yesterday, but
looking at the results, I
think it was a bit of an overreaction.
First of all,
looking at the Bloomberg news itself,
Meta is
planning a cloud infrastructure business to sell AI computing resources externally
.  If you just read the headline, you
could interpret it as Meta selling off surplus computing resources externally, implying that there is no longer any additional demand for CAPEX
.  yes.
Meta's stock price surged yesterday as the
market
interpreted this business strategy positively, believing it could help generate revenue from surplus computing resources and recoup investments in AI
.  Uh, looking at the internal situation, the
proprietary model Meta is building is
called Llama, but uh, since this model was
somewhat less competitive compared to competitors, it is
known that until recently, they were using the Jaminai model from their competitor, Google.
And
regarding the interpretation of the overall meta,
there is an assessment that although the CEO launched ultra-advanced AI development, aggressively recruited talent, and expanded infrastructure, he was unable to produce proper results.  However, Meta was
using Gemini on Google, but Google
restricted Meta's usage of Gemini
. As a result of this measure, part of Meta's
Project A was disrupted, and it is
reported that Meta took a hit because there was high demand for Google models.  So, this
is the Financial Times, and the
reason I am explaining this at length is that,
internally, our own model was
somewhat lacking or insufficient in terms of competitive advantage compared to our competitors
.  And regarding
that meta, while other
hyperscalers had cloud-external
sales,
in a situation where meta had no external sales, there
might have been some surplus.
However, there was likely a business judgment that it would be better to
utilize that surplus externally rather than internally, and
separately from that, the
internal model itself was somewhat lagging behind other competing businesses
.
I think it would be good to understand this background a bit.  If this
happens, it is highly likely that Meta will form a
new competitive landscape in the cloud market against leading companies such as AWS, Azure, and Google. However,
concerns have been raised in some quarters regarding Meta's plans that the company may have built an excessive amount of AI infrastructure, which is why it appears that a sell-off occurred
in the semiconductor and infrastructure sectors yesterday.
Furthermore, if Meta has secured
more GPUs and data centers than expected and
intends to sell the remaining resources externally, it could be interpreted that future additional
investment in AI infrastructure will decrease
.  However, while no
one can give a definitive answer regarding this matter, as you will
see later, according to
JP Morgan, which tracks the AI ​​CAPEX of hyperscalers every month, overall
AI CAPEX of hyperscalers
appears to have increased as of the end of June compared to last April.
Therefore, it seems difficult to view the total amount of AI infrastructure
investment itself as decreasing due to the meta
.
Meta's entry into the cloud business is
not new news, but
according to what was revealed during the Q3 2025 earnings call, there are
inquiries from external parties asking if they can use the surplus computing capacity, and it was
mentioned that if there is an overbuild or excess capacity, they can have the option to sell it externally
.  So,
in terms of having established the organization and the methodology for actual sales, it feels like it is becoming somewhat realistic
.  So, the
second newly established organization is called Meta Compit,
where
personnel are assembled to build and operate AI infrastructure.
One method involves developers
accessing AI models installed on the meta infrastructure and
paying for the computing power required to run them.
Another method is selling capacity to third parties, similar to
NeoCloud, where
computing capacity itself is sold. This is the
approach taken by NeoCloud providers such as Iden, Nevius, and Cowive.  yes.
Because their business structures completely overlap, the mere
fact that a strong competitor like Hanna has entered the market is
interpreted as a situation that could pose a threat to existing companies, which is why the
stock prices of NeoCloud companies
plummeted yesterday.  Uh, so far I have
roughly explained the background and
done some fact-checking.
If we look at the implications here,
Metacritic clearly has been in a somewhat volatile state regarding profit margins, as you can see below.
Since the profit margin announced for the second quarter came out at 35.7%—a level where the leading digit shifted to 7%—I believe there must have been considerable deliberation internally
.  If
you look at the CAPEX below, it is 33.6 billion, which is
almost double the amount from the first quarter of last year compared to the second quarter of last year
.  And in the next quarter as well, it
went from 39.6 billion to 6 billion, so while CAPEX continued to
increase, it seems there was considerable
internal concern regarding the decline in the profit margin
.  Given the
current market outlook, Meta’s
planned cloud
and computing sales are
not entirely new; however, recently,
SpaceX signed contracts to provide computing power,
receiving $1.25 billion per month from Entropic and about $
920 million from Google
.  And so, it is possible to conclude that Meta has also decided to
follow the example of a business model where surplus computing resources are sold for money on the web
.  Besides that, an
important point is
CAPEX from an investment perspective in the infrastructure sector. First of all,
Meta held its first-quarter earnings call on
April 29th, and during that session, it raised its
CAPEX guidance for the year
from 125 billion to
145 billion
.  He also said that
all the signals visible across the shoulder are
giving confidence in the investment.  And
while mentioning that, it appears that faith in
CAPEX investment has
continued up until now,
and the decision to
further increase existing CAPEX investment at this point can
also be
seen as a confirmation of that commitment to investment
.
Uh, however, the efficiency of the in-house developed AI
model is declining.  And
monitoring the decline in the profit margin relative to CAPEX investment, I
believe there was a strategic choice to make slight changes to the business structure.  Therefore, we will have to
wait and see how much this measure will help Meta improve sales, profits, or profit margins through some changes in the business via third-party sales, but I
think it is a much better decision than doing nothing.   For
example, the
stock price reacted once due to the narrative, [snorted] and I
think there will be details regarding this in the earnings announcement scheduled for July 29th.   Until
then, it seems there will be some volatility in
infrastructure-related stocks, including semiconductors, due to issues surrounding KEPFIX
.  It
seems that opinions could fluctuate depending on how much is wrong or how the interpretation itself is done, but I believe it is difficult to conclude that the
direction of AI and its infrastructure has
ended or been picked out based solely on this news
.  So, in the case of this meta, based
on PR, it went up a bit yesterday, but the
PR has dropped significantly from the 14x level to the 15x level.
Looking at the past year, it
went up to about 22 times, but due to the stock price decline, the
PR has dropped significantly.
As for Ford's EPS, we will have to wait and see, but I
think the market's expectations might rise a little following this announcement.
So, looking down, we are closely tracking
how the total volume of CAPEX from hyperscalers is changing. To
give you an update on the monthly CAPEX investment figures from JPMorgan Markets, when estimated at the end of April, the
2026 CAPEX was
723 billion,
2027 was 85 billion, and 2028 was
904 billion.
This was right
after the first quarter earnings announcements, and the latest
updated version was in effect.
Now, looking at the situation after about a month or two,
2026 is
758 billion, 2027 is
925 billion, and
2028 is 986 billion.
Generally, the estimates are showing a continuous
upward trend.  Well, as I
mentioned last time, I
think the upward adjustments caused by semiconductor prices, memory prices, and storage device prices are likely significantly reflected in this area.   That's
all.
thank you  First of all,
after listening to the story,
my mind changed again to Panrang, unlike when I said, "I think this way after hearing what our Yuri Pro told me
."
Ah, so how does it change?  Ah, I'm
not sure if this is an appropriate analogy, but after
listening to you speak, the thought that came to mind is, well
,
if we consider it in the context of a restaurant business, yes
.
Uh, there were large corporations that had
set up big stores on major streets and were running business
restaurants, and there were
also smaller
companies doing well in the alleyway commercial districts, operating according to their size. But the
big restaurants, uh, were
n't doing well and weren't getting many customers, so
yes.  I decided to cut the store on the main street in
half and move into the alleyway commercial district to do
business with my own brand
.  So,
from the perspective of a food supplier, it would be
good if the alleyway businesses used my ingredients, and the big restaurants and franchises on the main street took my ingredients to make food for their customers.
Even if there aren't many customers, the ingredients are still
sold anyway, so that is how the
overall business grows.
[Clears throat]
But if I reduce my presence on the main street and move to the
bustling commercial district, I might
worry that the amount of ingredients I can sell will decrease
.  This is
memory, right? When it comes to this business, I
thought until the end that it wouldn't be a direct blow due to the decrease in memory demand, but after
hearing the Vice President's explanation, my perspective
changed a bit and I realized that it could be.   hmm.  hmm.
[Snoring] Well, I think the
key lies in two things.
Hey, regarding
Meta's own
business decisions, they have been
internally utilizing that AI CAPEX by
building AI models to improve internal
efficiency until now, right?
We have been working on those parts, and regarding
how much they are being
improved and if there is room for
further improvement, well, if there is room for improvement, we could probably utilize the latest
GPUs or the
latest memory
.  And regarding the
computing resources established before that,
actually, they are models that are
somewhat difficult to use for building learning models right now
.  However, as the demand for outsourced products
continues to increase, there will certainly be external demand.
Therefore, from a business perspective, we need to strike
a balance between utilizing infrastructure to expand internal demand and fully launching external sales to boost overall revenue and profit margins. I think we need to provide
some details regarding this aspect
.  So,
first of all, looking at the third quarter and the
earnings call from the last first quarter, I mentioned that
even if we invest in CAPEX, we have faith and conviction in this [clears throat], did
n't I?  But
looking at it from two perspectives—that is, we have been doing
CAPEX so far and there is some left, so
we will
maintain that CAPEX or
not increase it further—
or are comments saying that
we need more CAPEX to completely change the business landscape,
focus more on external sales, and
move toward a different business model?  I'm not sure if we'll
go this way.
Ah, I think I need to check this a bit more
.
yes.  Uh, the fact that you showed the quarterly results like this
.  And looking at the estimates, the
sales growth rate is slowing down, and the
operating profit margin is also continuously declining, so...
uh, we need to somehow get out of this situation
.  It seems clear that there is a lot of internal deliberation
.  yes.
Our Mr. Moon Sang-hoon.   yes
.  Vice President,
what are your thoughts on the materials you prepared
?
yes.
Priest,
please summarize the point we discussed earlier.  yes.   I am
thinking in the same context
.
First of all, I understand that the training for the Chajad model has now been
completed.
So Meta is
yes.   It
looks like it will launch in a few months, but until then,
that cutting-edge capacity has to sit idle
.
It seems like they are currently using those items for external sales.   hmm.
That does
n't mean there is a lot of demand for meta right now, though.  The same goes for the
Spex Grok.
You can view it as the same scheme
.  So, regarding this, it
seems it is still too early to judge whether CAPEX is only done in the state.
Very clearly [laughs]
uh, it is still quite too early to worry about the overall investment
cycle turning around
.
yes.  I think it will reflect time a little more
Well, in terms of the meta itself, the fact that the stock price rose by more than 8% yesterday—if we
compare it to a company—is understandable given the
expectation that the capacity utilization rate, which was at a low level, might rise a bit
.  The stock price has been very sluggish lately, and
looking at the stock price reaction, the
absolute leaders in the existing cloud business are actually
AWS, Microsoft, and
uh, Google.  Uh, they
account for about 60%, and they are launching the Metaguy
business in earnest.   A
business
player is coming in from the cloud side.  If the market perception that "a strong
competitor is entering" had
spread, well, since
another player was entering the existing, well-performing cloud market, I think their
stock price should have taken a hit as well
.  hmm.
But considering they just stayed put for reasons like there being nothing right in the past or their
stock prices having already dropped, and
also because they are
now in direct competition with NeoCloud companies—whose
stocks had already risen and who are
physically weaker—shouldn't we also consider whether they were the only ones to
take a hit
?
If this were truly critical,
I think Google,
Microsoft, and
Amazon would have to be punished as well
.   I
think the reason it didn't happen is that the cloud market already implies that supply is exceeding demand, and
since the stock price had already fallen significantly, there was
no room for it to fall further.  Also, the
valuation multiple itself
has dropped significantly.  I wonder if this part was also left
alone.  And as for
those unrelated software stocks, judging by how
much they rose yesterday, I
think it was just a shift in supply and demand, a shift in sentiment, sector expansion, or a easing of market concentration—something like that, just cooling down the overheating a bit.
Hmm.  All right.   Since it is
difficult for us to finalize the new issuance based on just a single day's analysis of how the U.S. market continues to change, I
trust that President Choi Bo will persistently continue to track the situation, so we will stop here for
today and move on
.  Let's move on to the domestic market
.  What happened to the Korean market yesterday
?  Chairman.
Ah, yes.  I will speak about the exclusive market
.  The KOSPI closed down 2%,
while the KOSDAQ rose 1.4%,
showing differentiation in indices.  In terms of supply and demand,
individual investors
made spot purchases worth 1.7 trillion won, while foreign
investors showed selling pressure of approximately 1.7 trillion won
.  In foreign futures, there was also a
strong inflow of buying pressure as they purchased about 1.7 trillion won
.
Looking at trading trends by investment type, it appears that foreign investors strongly bought semiconductor materials, parts, and equipment stocks, such as DBI-Tech, Samsung Electro-Mechanics,
Reno Gongyeop, Hanmi Semiconductor, EOTech,
HPSP, and Solbrain
.  In addition, looking at the selling side, I
sold Samsung Electronics, SK Square, Isu Petasys, Hyundai Motor, EcoPro, and Huseong.
During the period, I purchased SK QCare, Jusung Engineering,
ISU, PETA, Hyosung Heavy Industries, Hana Aerospace,
Samsung Electric, etc.  During
the period, SK NIX,
Samsung Electronics, HPSP, Hanmi Semiconductor, and
Lee Dong-ho were sold.   There
were 22 52-week highs.
Shinsegae, K-Citec, and Geummo Construction hit new highs on the KOSPI
.  With Geummo Construction feeling like it was hitting the daily limit, and companies like
PSK, Simtek, Eugene Tech,
Tess, VM, InBody, and Inteplus
hitting new highs on the
KOSDAQ, it certainly
seemed like there were a noticeable number of materials, parts, and equipment companies there.   Well, it
seems like the Korean market was a good fit for the term "sector spread." Uh,
looking at the foreign selling, yesterday was
based on the exchange rate, right, Manager?  With selling
pressure around 1.7 trillion won, it was
enough to make one wonder if they were stopping or had sold everything once 1 or 2 trillion won was sold.
Buying sentiment had been extremely strong until now, but it has
subsided somewhat. I am watching to see how things unfold today. Listening to what
industry
acquaintances are saying, there were
quite a few closed funds during the first half of the year, and there were
many trades confirming performance. So, while I do
n't see the calendar continuing from the perspective of a perpetual company, from the standpoint of the stock price, it
could become an important turning point in terms of supply and demand. Therefore, I am
interested in whether foreign selling will decrease in July, and for now, it does seem to have
decreased somewhat.  I am
selling, but I would like to see these aspects.
[Snoring] Uh, and yesterday, after
closing the market, I noticed that in the case of Reno Industrial,
foreigners
bought over 1 million shares, yes.  Uh,
domestic institutions
sold over 1 million shares, and the volume was so large that I wondered if it was done at Jangchung or if it was a
block deal before or after the market closed yesterday
.  I
was a bit curious about those parts.  If
there were any blocks, I will check today
because I can see the previous day's data when I enter the exchange
.  As we
dealt with the Korean market throughout yesterday, the first day of July, did you
notice any changes, Doctor Wang?
How was it?  Ah, yes.  If you look at the
market trends over the past few days, starting from yesterday, as
Samsung Electronics and SK Hynix were being manipulated little by little, there was some
rotational buying in other directions
.
Actually, earlier today, we were
a bit upset seeing our staking stocks drop
.  So today, well, since
Samsung Zinc has fallen, it
seems natural that it will start with a decline. [Clears throat] If we look at
the situation from a month ago, when
Samsung Zinc dropped sharply by more than 5%,
other stocks fell very hard as well
.
Hmm, you know that's what happened
.   They are in the same boat,
but recently, the drop in
Samsung Electronics and SK Hynix wasn't that big
.  As a result, the
sales were shifting in a different direction, but I am also
curious to see how things will turn out today
.   hmm.
So, I am thinking that I should take a look at that part later while watching the market
.
And looking through it, there was a lot of
ETF trading when you mentioned the stocks you bought and sold.
Yes.   It looks like it,
but there isn't much.
I'm not sure how to interpret these parts either.   I'm not
sure about the [laughter] that Manager Oh's ETF trading brings.  To put it
simply, there are
many investors
in Electronics, and since the stock price has
dropped significantly in the short term, let
's think about
selling the ETF and
buying the individual stock instead of the ETF.  hmm.
I wonder if he might have had a personality like that.   hmm.   It
seems that direct trading of individual stocks has increased because the movements of top-performing stocks by market capitalization, which could be included as underlying assets, have slowed down.  [Snorting] It is
very flexible.  I will try to understand it to that extent and
move on.  Shall we take a look at the stocks
?   yes
.  yes.  Looking at the semiconductor sector yesterday,
large semiconductors did not perform well.   With
Samsung Electronics closing down 5.8% and
SKNIX also falling 3.4%, it
seems the trend in major semiconductor stock prices has been weakening somewhat recently.  The materials, parts, and equipment stocks below are still pretty
similar.  The market continues to be mixed, with some
stocks surging while others undergo some correction
.  Stocks like EOTechnics, which had risen significantly last week,
also
turned bearish, and on the previous day, Park
Systems.
Jusung Engineering
recorded a 20% surge, even though there didn't seem to be any particular issue
.  Simtek went up by about 6%
.  Isu Petasis was one of the
companies whose stock price had been moving the most sluggishly among PCB manufacturers, but yesterday it
appears to have succeeded in a sharp rebound of about 13%.   The
IT sector closed up 1%
.  LG Electronics and LG
Innotek closed lower again
.  LG Innotek's stock price has
fallen 40% based on the price.
Was it until the middle of last month?   It
rose really hot, but I get the
feeling that it is finding its fundamentals
.  [Laughs]
Yes.  yes.  I
mentioned last time that it might have been a bit excessive, and I
think I was right.   My
voice was a bit weak back then.   It was
too strong, contrary to what I expected.   yes
.  That thought crossed my mind.   On
the other hand, Samsung Electronics is quite solid.  I have
recorded a 10% profit this month.  Uh,
Naver in the platform sector performed poorly, and the rest of the
stocks were flat overall.   The
Nikkei index closed up 0.6% and 6%
.   It seemed
a bit different domestically, but
generally speaking, the IT stocks here were all
good.  With Tokyo Electron up 2%,
Disco 4%, Ibidem 8%, and
Murata rising about 4%, everything was
good for MLCCs, substrates, and equipment.
Looking at Hyundai Motor's automobiles, Hyundai has
been somewhat sluggish.   While there
was some differentiation as the expected price rose by 2.5% to 5%, Hyundai Motor is
currently down tenfold, so I do
think it might be about time for some supply to come in
.  If you look at the consumer sector,
LG Household & Health Care, Amore,
Cosmax, Cosmecca Korea, and other
substitute cosmetics and OEM/ODM companies performed
quite well.  Cosmecca
Korea definitely showed a stronger trend
.
Looking at the skin beauty device sector, it seems that the supply of beauty devices from Classys, Hugel, and APR
PV has been
gradually increasing recently.
And
looking at the recent trends, PharmaResearch seems to be relatively stronger.  Although it
went up 1% yesterday, I
think the recent trend is the best among mobile devices.  In the
food sector below, medicinal products were
rising for the first time in a while, and department store chains were not
bad either.
Looking at other sectors, the performance of shipbuilding stocks yesterday wasn't
bad.  Hyundai Heavy Industries rose by about 4%,
and Hana Ocean, Hana Engine, and
others showed an upward trend.  Hana
Ocean had a public announcement this morning.   It has been
officially confirmed that the priority contractor for the KDDX project has been selected.
So right now,
there is a situation where it is surging by about 10% in the NXT market.
What is KDDX?
Domestic Gunnam Project.
Domestic Military Troop Project.  hmm.  So, the
competition was between Hyundai Heavy Industries, Hana, and Ocean.  There has been a lot of
talk since last year about the move toward Hana Ocean, but
since it was officially confirmed almost certainly today, the
stock price seems to have gained some momentum
.
So, if you look at the valuations of shipbuilding stocks on the right, they are
all trading at less than 20 times
.  So, uh [snorting],
starting this year and into next year and the year after,
high-priced shipbuilding volumes will be exported, but the
valuation is less than 20 times, and if you
look at profit growth in terms of P-value, they have all likely dropped below 1
.  From that perspective, I
think there is still room for upside, and the
trend of defense stocks below was also good.   I
just saw the price drop below 1 million
won and thought, "Oh, it's dropping below 1 million won," but the
rebound was quite strong the very next day, yesterday
.  Nex Hyundai Rotem
was also strong.  There weren't any special issues here either
.  As the value decreased, it
seems like it showed a strong upward trend when Sun-Nammae was playing.  It seems like the biotech sectors below were all on their
own.  There were some
stocks that went up and some that went down a bit
.  In the securities sector, Kiwoom Securities
showed an upward trend of about 1.3% to 3%.  Uh,
after reading a few recent reports, it seems that, as
we mentioned before, we are also taking a share of
Key Securities' market within Korea Investment & Securities
.  There
are also some stories like this.  But then again, some
reports also mentioned things like that
.  With trading volumes showing signs of some
talk regarding a pick-out, stock
prices of securities firms have fallen significantly recently. However,
looking at the reports released yesterday, it seems the prices have dropped
to a level where all that noise has already been fully reflected
.
There were reports like this.  So, we need to
wait and see how much the stock prices, which have fallen significantly recently, can recover. The
entertainment sector also
generally succeeded in rebounding yesterday, even though there were no special issues
.  And the transformer side was quite
good.  Hyundai 1, Hyosung Heavy Industries, and LS
1-Reck also showed an upward trend of about 10%
.  I saw that Slater recently, and the
LS Daejeon section looked really
good. Hmm hmm.
All right.  I also
grouped up stocks of interest by sector yesterday, but was there any
particular news regarding Gangsan
?  How was it?   There was
absolutely nothing, and it seems like there wasn't any individual news at
all. But,
um,
defense stocks fell a lot globally
.  Defense stocks, especially in Europe
.  However, European defense stocks are
showing signs of a gradual rebound, so
from that perspective, it seems that buying pressure has
flowed in to find the bottom.   hmm.
In the grand scheme of things, if a stock price
falls too much, there is actually always a technical rebound, no matter how poor the company's fundamentals are
.
Now, to put it in a
very simplified way using the PG
concept, there are
companies that rebound even when you wonder, "Is the multiple really falling this low despite this profit growth?" The
former and the latter are clearly different, but
looking at it overall, regarding sectors or
things like that, considering the latter concept—as you
explained about shipbuilding stocks earlier—
which other sectors do you see that have fallen too much?
Ultimately, this seems to lead to questions such as which sector to invest in when the semiconductor market takes a break,
enters a box, or turns bearish
.   hmm.
[Clears throat] Uh, regarding the
latter—the companies you mentioned that dropped below PG 1—
I think the defense and shipbuilding industries are the representative ones
.  And moving on to food and beverage, it's a
company like Samyang Foods.  I see that beauty devices from
companies like PharmaResearch and APR have become much more affordable. If we
look at what was good before the semiconductor rally, it was sectors like
PEU costs, defense, shipbuilding, and transformers that rose driven by export momentum
.  Of course, one
could say that the transformer sector will continue to be intertwined with AI, but
ultimately, if the semiconductor sector takes a break this time and leading
stocks
shift elsewhere even temporarily, I think the
shipbuilding and defense sectors—which have solid earnings and lower valuations—would be the
best options.
All right.
Today, I’m going to move on to a slightly earlier time with the report
.   Since it is the
beginning of the month, I will look at the import and export statistics. Yes,
yes.  Import and export trends have been released.   It is a position that
comes out every month from the Ministry of Trade, Industry and Energy
.  Looking at export performance first, it came out to $10.2 billion, an
increase of 9% from 70.9% in the same month of the previous year
.
With imports rising 30% to $66 billion, the
trade figures continue to record a surplus
.  There was a comment regarding the semiconductor sector, stating that
memory chips recorded their
highest-ever monthly export
performance as prices continued to rise.  In terms of price, the
rate of increase compared to the previous day has eased.   The
upward trend itself continued for both DRAM and NAND
.  Please take a look at the fixed and growth rates of major memory products for
reference
.  With robust demand and
rising fixed prices leading to higher export unit prices, it
can be said that the highest monthly performance in history was achieved.  If
you look at the semiconductor export unit prices, they come out as 4, 5, and 6 for 2020
.
$5.4 million per kg for DRAM.
And uh, it was $54,000 in April
.
$60,000 came out in May and June.  So it
went down a bit.   yes
.  DRAM prices
are showing signs of dropping slightly, but
looking at the analysts' kick comments yesterday, there was a
concentrated outflow of low-priced volumes around the end of June
.  As of the end of June.  I did
see some comments suggesting that might have influenced the price.   On
the other hand, the land side is definitely doing very well and
continues to show a good trend.
With scores of 4.6, 5.7, and 6,
it seems Land still showed a solid performance.   I
'm talking about computer SSDs.
Demand for global data centers, centered on the U.S., is increasing significantly, and
demand for AI servers is expanding, with plans for mass production of VeraRubin
.  So, it is said that it has been
recording triple-digit growth rates for five consecutive months
.
Looking at computer export figures, there has been a continuous upward trend, with $2.6 billion in February, $
3.4 billion in March, $4.1 billion in April, $
4.2 billion in May, and $5.4 billion in June
.  Below are the
trends in export value and export growth rate.
Export value continues to rise,
and the export growth rate is also continuously
increasing.  Also, it can be seen that the slope is continuously
increasing, and
this pattern appears because of Y and Y and Y.   Oh, if you
move to the right and look at the
export figures by major 20 items for June,
semiconductors recorded the highest ranking in history and are showing an
increase of about 200% year-on-year
.  If
you take a look at the computer SSD section, it also ranked first all-time,
showing a 308% increase year-on-year.
I think the car turned out pretty well, too.  So, it
can be seen that it ranked first in all-time rankings
.  Besides that, it
seems that petroleum products, electricity, electrical appliances, agricultural and marine products, and cosmetics were also showing good trends.
I think the cosmetics are really good.   Since it
increased by 42% year-on-year, I think we can
view the overall business conditions as not bad
.  Below are the semiconductor export figures and
growth rates.   It is
still recording a very high growth rate year by year
.  We tend to pay close attention to when the year-
on-year growth rate and slope of semiconductor exports turn downward, but
for now, it looks like things will continue to be good compared to July, August, and September
.   It
looks like it will exceed three digits, and well, even looking ahead to
December, I think we can
expect stagnant growth.
So, I don't think the growth rate itself will drop in the second half of this year
?  Hmm, that
thought crossed my mind a bit.  Uh,
looking at the export value and growth rate by major region
, China, the US, India, and ASEAN
all ranked first in history, while
Japan seemed to rank around third
.  Well, looking at it overall, I think it can be
considered the best performance in history
.
First, among the four tables you showed me, I would like to
briefly ask only the ones I am curious about before moving on
.  If you look at the top left,
there are bar graphs showing export volume and export growth rate, and
the colors of the bars are slightly different.  What is the
meaning of this?  Is that so, Vice President
?   hmm.  I don't know   Right
?  It doesn't seem like this is dragging on year by year, either
.
ah.  ah.
That's right.  uh.  It does
n't seem like the increase or decrease is represented by color, so I'm not
sure.   yes
.  If anyone in our Milton happens to know, please let
me know.   uh
.
I want to ask Mr. Oh just one thing for sure before moving on.
I vaguely
hear from the outside that although I participate in this Morning Brief, the
export growth rate tends to decline around September.
This is firmly ingrained in my mind. If you
look at the chart at the top left, the slope has been steepening since around the third quarter of last year, so I
think my memory is correct.
However, looking specifically at semiconductor exports, as
Manager Oh mentioned, since these triple-digit figures started this
year, I
have mixed thoughts on whether the growth rate could remain very high until December.
So, when we said that it might flatten out starting around September, were we
referring to the overall export statistics
?   yes
.
I think you can understand it that way.  First off, regarding semiconductors, it seems like
things will be very good until the second half of the year, but
um, if you look at the slope of individual companies, specifically the
QQ, MOM, or QQ profit growth of Samsung Electronics or SK Hynix in the second half, they aren't
flattening out but rather dropping steadily.   hmm.
Yes. If we look solely at the growth rate, export
data reflects the overall trend, but if
we want to connect this to investment,
the slope is what matters. It
was estimated that both electronics and NIX would fall to single digits.   It
is the fourth quarter starting around when.
Even up until the 3rd quarter, [I scoffed]. I
understand that the 2nd quarter is around 80% and 60%, and it drops to 30% during the 3rd quarter
.  Now, in a situation where the slope is falling,
unfortunately, issues and noise regarding Meta, as well as the
launch of leveraged ETFs and ADR
listings—
which caused a strong rebound driven by short-term momentum—
made the pace of the stock price rise too steep. I felt that a
process of repentance is necessary as a result, so I think it was
correct to conclude that it is very difficult to make a judgment based solely on the export growth rate
.  I think it would be more helpful for investment to look at individual semiconductor companies and
examine their profit growth rates
.   yes
.  That's right.
We need to look more closely at the individual company level from a bottom-up perspective, but Mr.
Yun-sang, the price you mentioned earlier has
dropped a little.
That part doesn't seem like good news anyway, but
is it something we should just let slide?
Is this news that we should take seriously?
Actually, semiconductors are
n't sold on a per-gram basis.
yes.  I think it would be better to just view this as a warehouse metric
and check it on a quarterly basis
.  It seems that the
quarterly unit is a context where volatility can be somewhat reduced compared to the monthly unit of 11 or 20 days
.   hmm.
All right.  So, Mr. Oh, is that all the materials you have
prepared regarding import and export statistics
?   yes
.   yes
.  I’m going to move on to the next report
.  It's been a while since I've been to the entertainment section. I think I
asked Manager Oh about this a long time ago, but I'll ask him again
.  These days, when you decide which company report to discuss
tomorrow, how
many do you usually look at to make your decision?   I
really don't watch it much these days.  Ah, I mean, there is nothing to see
.
Uh, there is a
world of difference between not looking at the report and having nothing to look at
.
Those reports aren't coming out well.
Regarding reports on individual stocks,
even in the entertainment sector, if you look at recent reports like the HYBE report, the
last one was about three weeks ago.
Industry reports for companies like SM and YG are still being released occasionally.   Since
this has been so marginalized, I
understand that requests for seminars from organizations like corporations have also decreased significantly for researchers
.  I heard that even though we
held a seminar once, there were hardly any
requests.  As a result, it seems like they are
writing physical reports on a trial-and-error basis, so
except for major industries linked to the semiconductor and AI value chains, not many reports are
coming out.
I used to bring the exact
same IT stocks and semiconductors every morning,
and there was a
reason for it.  yes.
It seems like there was such a trend.  But
if individual stocks start to recover again, would
n't we see a lot more reports coming out about the entertainment or other sectors?  I have a
feeling that...  Regarding the report on the entertainment sector,
Researcher Lee Ki-woon commented that the overall market is currently in an absurdly undervalued range.   It
was a short report.  They recommend a strong increase in weighting due
to a steeper price correction than the expected period correction
.
Stock prices have been quite sluggish due to supply and demand issues focused on AI, but
second-quarter earnings are generally
expected to be around the consensus level.  It is said that even underperforming companies are
expected to have strong earnings momentum with high downside risk
.  It is said that the 5th generation, Cortiz and
Catchhain, are growing at a pace that will change history, and
this is expected to have a
positive impact on the growth of the Kyungjin Group
.  The opinion is that we should take advantage of the opportunity to increase our position,
as the price correction has been steeper than the expected timeframe
.  I interpreted the fact that the stock prices are trading at around
22 times for HIVE and 12 to
15 times for SMJPY as being
significantly undervalued
.  It was estimated that Q2 earnings would be
consistent with HIVE SM and JPYG would reconcile
.  It is said that HYVE is expected to achieve record-
breaking performance thanks to BTS's historic world tour
.  SM is also
expected to achieve strong results as NCT, Wish, Rise, and aespa make simultaneous comebacks.  Uh, I
think JP will be a bit sluggish.   It is
predicted that Stray Kids will achieve their highest performance in the second half of the year with a comeback and large-scale tour, and it is said that
Wise is also preparing for a new male group within the year, starting in August, to celebrate Beat's 20th anniversary
.  Concerns regarding 4th-year earnings are
very positive, but due to the
absence of BTS's all-time record-breaking performance,
the sector's stock prices
recorded a 40 to 50% decline in just four months.
HYBE's stock price has fallen from its historical low of an expected
multiple of 30 times
to 2 times, a 30% decrease.  The remaining three companies also
broke through their lows by 15 times and
fell to 10 times based on SM.
In order to resolve this extreme undervaluation,
HYV's second-quarter earnings have
become significantly important in the short term, given concerns regarding BTS's share distribution ratio.   With
cumulative tour revenue for May and April announced through overseas media, it is
expected that high expectations will be met, and
this is expected to provide a high sense of stability to the outlook for performance in the second half of the year
.  So, it is said that the 5th generation is
growing rapidly
.  The
modernization issue for Ateen is already expected to be resolved to the point where eight members can be active starting from the second quarter of next year, and if
HYBE rebounds, it is expected that Tak Entertainment will also
rise in tandem.
I made a prediction.  Below
is the valuation table.   The
blue line at the very top is HIVE, the white one is
JP, the red one is SM, and the
purple one is Y Entertainment
.  So,
as Yong Gu-won mentioned earlier,
HYIVE has now dropped to its low valuation
.
Well, it seems like it's even worse in other industries and companies
.  Well, SM hit tenfold and
managed to rebound a little.  Uh, I
think it's a similar flow.  About
13 times my size.  Ah, YG is 13 times.
And
since trading is taking place at about 12 times the value, all
entertainment companies are trading at very low valuations.  So
actually, even
when it was trading at about 15 times its value, a report of this kind
came out.  But after that
report came out and it rebounded for a day,
supply and demand shifted heavily toward semiconductors again, and it has
dropped to the low 10-fold range.   The
current valuation is indeed in a very attractive
range.  However, one thing to check
is that HYBE ultimately needs to survive, and
since BTS's earnings will be fully reflected in the second quarter results, we
can see how the distribution ratio turned out.  So,
if performance is good despite the distribution being like that,
HYBE could rebound in earnest, and
if the top stock rebounds, I think there is a possibility that it will eventually follow suit with JP, SM, and
YG
.   yes
.  Thank you for your effort   I have a
webinar with the securities firm's P-Bs.  I just
finished the webinar and came back in a little while ago
.
Uh, the export and import volume data above
is a very important part.
When we film the monthly forecast data this evening, I will also
show you this export value and export growth trend
.  You can consider that Korea's KOSPI
moves exactly like this export growth rate
.  So, from 2024 to the
first half of 2025, there was
no growth rate of thousands in Korean stocks—well, even looking ahead to 2023, it isn't visible—but there was no such thing.  They say 2023 is the right
time for semiconductors, so I
guess the domestic market isn't doing well.
The reason I mentioned escaping the director position was that there was nothing
distinct in the increase or decrease of exports.
But doesn't the
export growth rate skyrocket starting from the second half of 2025
? Stock prices
moved while reflecting this in advance, and the biggest factor influencing the export growth rate is, of course,
semiconductors, right? Semiconductors account for
$44.8 billion, while others include automobiles at $6.7 billion,
machinery at $4 billion, and petrochemicals at $4 billion and $5 billion. Since semiconductors make up
$44.8 billion of the total $10.2 billion,
right?
yes.  It's almost 45%, and
right now, Samsung Electronics and SK
Hynix account for over 50% of our country's total market capitalization
.
yes.  That is correct.
yes.  That aspect is now accurately
reflected, so when will that export saturation rate start to
decline?   As for
when it will turn around, if you
look at the data Manager Park Seong-gu prepared just now, the semiconductor
growth rate eventually has to decline.  The semiconductor
growth rate is expected to turn downward starting from September and October. While I do
n't think the base low will be low,
since semiconductor prices surged after last September, the export
growth rate will likely show signs of slowing down once this September and October pass.
Consequently, I believe there
is a high probability that the KOSPI will enter a "box range" from the second half of this year through next year. As
I mentioned earlier, the period from 2012 to 2015 was a massive stock market
.
That kind of market will unfold, and the
conclusion I mentioned in that webinar is that, while in
the past it
was important whether or not I bought a house, this time, the important thing is whether or
not I invested in stocks. If
you mishandle the strategy of targeting these leading stocks that are currently moving based on momentum, it will be like
starting from the beginning, just as before the semiconductor market started moving.  Jo Bang-won started with skin care, beauty, and entertainment, and
then if you
look at semiconductors, the growth rate came out to 199%
.  This month, too, June.  So, the
growth rate is 308% for computers, and while the
growth rates for other things are decent,
things like 18.8%, 17%, and 49% just
don't even register.
However, if the slope of the semiconductor growth rate
becomes gentle like this, the
semiconductor market will enter a trading range. Therefore, once it
enters this range,
if you have used trend-following strategies until now, you
should effectively utilize contrarian strategies until next year.   hmm.
That is the strategy we explained, and if we
look at what will bounce up when it enters this trading range, the answer is actually already
determined.  If we invest while looking for places with
guaranteed profit growth within the next five years, or even
until the beginning of the year after next, anyway,
our clients'
assets have grown tremendously through stocks, haven't they?  Right?   yes
.  It has increased a lot.   It has
increased dramatically over the past three years. It’s gotten to the point where even
the person who scoffed two years ago saying they were stressed because they couldn't buy a house back then could probably
afford to buy one this time.  You understood exactly what I
meant.  Right?
With this level of return on investment, it
seems like it would be okay to buy a house, and you can
assume that this kind of market will continue until the beginning of my next five years.
Now, next, the report says that Entertainment is in a
ridiculously undervalued range
.  [Clears throat]
Yes.
So, uh, [snorting] the
reason we continue doing 1-time management or lab work even recently is that there are just so
many ridiculously undervalued stocks.  But why did it
drop so ridiculously?  Because semiconductors are so
good.   hmm.
yes.  So, when semiconductors are doing well, you should
stick to them and trade, but once the slope of the semiconductor market starts to
turn a bit,
those ridiculously undervalued stocks will start to shoot
up again.
You can view it that way now. Yesterday, there was some talk on the window about
methane and things like that, but
my son has already
aired.  My son came here because he had a
presentation related to AI at 4X this time, and
I heard something important yesterday from what he told me.
We were looking at NVIDIA's
Lera Rubin and things like that, and thinking, 'Wow, there is
demand,' everyone from
Meta to others has been pouring massive amounts of
money into AI infrastructure investment, right?  Even if it turns out to be overinvestment,
overinvestment is less dangerous right now
. You’ve been harping on about this for two years, haven't you?   hmm.
But regarding the current situation, they were saying exactly that
.  To put it extremely, those who invested heavily in that
AI infrastructure are currently only
utilizing about 5% of it.   hmm.
Since the term "utilization" was used, you know that we are
aware that what we have invested here so far is full, so we need to keep investing more
.   Yeah,
yeah.
But from the
perspective of AI hardware and software, they have been relentlessly pouring
cutting-edge infrastructure investments into AI hardware,
yes.
Utilization... so hey, should
n't we be using this to make money now?  One of the plans is to
move the facilities at MetaA's data center to the
cloud
.   yes
.
So, since even Big Tech isn't enough, and
even the Neo Cloud market is already saturated with Big Tech companies, there needs to be
demand for Neo Cloud providers to succeed.   yes
.
The reason Neo Cloud is collapsing is
that the capacity released by Big Tech is
n't full; it's overflowing.  Oh, then there is
no need to use NeoCloud
.
At the same time, regarding NeoCloud being destroyed, if
that logic is correct, then the current
utilization is not
running at 100% capacity, but rather there is a
situation of excessive overinvestment.
Hmm,
that logic is cheap, but NeoCloud's stock price has been
destroyed,
right?  yes.  Anyway, with that concept in mind, I did
n't expect the market to react like this just a day after hearing the news. As for the
concept, I suggest those of us who used to harvest honey give it some
thought, and there are
many people in that field, you know.  Those of you there, please try taking
this test regarding that aspect
together.   Well
, that is how you should look at it.
How is the market doing right now
?   yes
.  The market started down 4.46%
.  It is currently falling
by -5.34%,
widening the decline further
.   yes
.   It started with an
8, but it's broken.   yes
.   It is
heading toward 7,850, and what about the KOSDAQ
?
Yes, the KOSDAQ started down 2.67%.  It
is currently -4%.   On top of
that, the international 10-year yield
spiked again yesterday, right?  It went back to 4.4.
yes.  4.
There is 1.4p.   If
oil prices are like that, it's a bit of a 10-year dramatic installment plan.   It just needs to
drop steadily, and as I will
explain the strategy for the next three months earlier,
everyone is expecting the June CPI, which will be announced in July, to drop to around 4.0.
But there is the June CPI.  I
even asked my son about the World Cup boom, but he says it's swarming with panic
.   hmm.   In
the US, the roads are now
packed, and wow, people are going on trips a lot
.  The US could do that, but
since it is so crowded, will the June CPI
come out at 4.0?  I...
um.
On the contrary, it won't fall.   hmm.
So I
thought it would come out at 4.0, but if it turns out to be 4.1 or 4.2
like this, shouldn't we
raise the interest rate on July 29th?   yes
.  That will serve as a
factor that can be described as a key theme in the market in various ways. Regarding the
July CPI announced in August and the August CPI announced in September,
since there is a one or two-month lag in oil prices, the
PPI will start dropping sharply from that point on,
yes.  The CPI is falling and employment figures are also
poor.   hmm.   And
yet, are you talking about a 10-year state affairs bill?  By the time September arrives, would
n't it be possible for it to slightly drop from 4.2 to 4.0?
yes.  On the other hand, while the market has always been
bad in September, this time we are
taking the hit a bit early, and I am
considering the overall outlook from the end of August into September
.  So, looking at today's decline, you know how
some people
often talk about this.  It does not mean that the market will end once the semiconductor sector is finished
.   It was
n't a market that started with semiconductors;
amidst high interest rates,
companies with good earnings started with the skincare, beauty,
and entertainment sectors. If semiconductors perform well, the market
shifts back to them. Since it is a market where funds continuously flow into and trade in sectors with strong performance,
you shouldn't blindly go in one direction. Once the
semiconductor sector ends, the market is over.  Even if you
think about it too much, everyone in the
US market expected a rebound yesterday,
right?  Yes, it's missing.
Yes,
what do you think will happen today?  Everyone is probably worried about whether this will
drop immediately and trigger a rebound buying rally,
or if the
decline will continue.
What do you think, Yuri Pro?   wait for
a sec.
Is the morning session ending tonight?
Yes, that is correct.  Uh,
it runs until 1 PM.   Yes, until
1 PM
.  yes.  US 6 hours.  Uh, and there is
no market on Friday.
Yes, that is correct.
And our stadium manager wrote it down yesterday, did
n't he?  There has never been a peak in June
since 1950.   hmm.
So, if you look at the market yesterday, uh,
semiconductors are falling, but big tech
hypermarkets are surging.   hmm.
yes.  That part is the one our Chief Chae mentioned earlier regarding the
estimated Capex of the Hyperskeletons, you know.   But
we need to think carefully about this estimate as well, because the
estimate has been continuously
rising recently.
Yes. It’s
not a matter of planning to build one data center and then deciding to build two or three because we needed two; rather, it is
because the costs would increase
.   yes
.  Hey, I originally thought it was $50 billion, but
hey, it looks like it won't even reach $50 billion
.  Because everything has gone up, starting with storage devices like
ESSD.  So, the
recent upward revision of CAPEX was made to
reflect the rise in prices
.  But later, if prices
fall, this could somewhat reverse the situation and
worsen investor sentiment like a domino effect. As
semiconductor spot prices and fixed-price contracts
drop, if prices fall, then regarding the
next CAPEX guidance—uh,
last time it was set at $90 billion,
uh,
$80 billion? Yes, yes,
investment
costs are actually decreasing because prices have fallen. Hey, is
n't the AI ​​infrastructure investment cycle over now?
There is also a possibility that it will be interpreted haphazardly like this again.  you're right.  That is correct.
So, regarding the reason Meta
raised the Capex estimate, if you
look at the subsequent interpretation, Meta itself
additionally explained that they had no choice but to raise the Capex costs because semiconductor prices had risen too much
.  yes.  What you said is
accurate.
yes.
Consequently, when semiconductor prices
fall,
from the perspective of hype scalers—since
net cash flow is calculated by subtracting CAPEX from operating cash flow—the
burden of CAPEX decreases.
Naturally, the
net operating cash flow, which enables shareholder returns, will
increase, and the stock price will naturally follow suit
.
Because it is likely to show an upward trend, if you look at the US market as a whole, there is
actually a high possibility that it will go up
.
That is the case for the attendant.
yes.
With the M7s and Tesla on Elon Musk's side, they
all have to keep
going with that concept, right?  They had to invest in humanoid
robots, and they also
continuously
needed semiconductors in this area for autonomous driving. So, if the
semiconductor market happens to take a downturn, their stock prices will
go up.
you're right.  yes.  So,
as I continued investing while constantly testing the messages the market gives me and my own thoughts, stocks became interesting.   Right
?
Yes, that is correct.  It is both fun and
challenging.  yes.
Yes, that is correct.
Okay, then, what about the domestic... ah, the U.S.
?  I do
think it might rise tonight.  It looks like SP will definitely
go up.
Uh, definitely.  yes.   yes yes
.   For now, I will discuss it
tomorrow morning and
evening. While there is a possibility that I might reverse my decision during the broadcast on Saturday, in
any case, with the employment
figures coming out today and considering consumer spending power and
other factors, as I
mentioned earlier, I believe the macroeconomic outlook for the US market is
sound. Therefore, as the internal rotation continues to
find profitable sectors and supply and demand
do not drop, I do not think the index
itself will remain stable
.
When you look at Yuri Pro's face, she speaks
with a significant amount of pressure regarding the prospects of having a child, and that is
actually true.
I've seen a lot of
feedback in the comments, you know.  It hurts when you come and say, "I told you back then, but you were
wrong," or something like that
.  hmm.
Of course.  As long as one is human.   That's right
.  [Laughs] As long as I'm human.   When I see
evil Buddha, I feel hurt and yes.  When you look at Writer Kang, he
seems like someone who just lives life his own way, but at the very end, he says that.   If you
press Like, I like it too, and if you
press Dislike, I really
hate it too.   I
don't read the comments.  But yesterday, the
index moved like this as an unexpected issue broke out.
Uh, why didn't I think of this?  This is a
bit much, isn't
it?
You know I've always said that.  My
IQ is 80, and the market Q is 20,000. Is
n't it precisely because of that 20,000 that we are attempting the challenge?   That's right
.  you're right.  yes.  You know how mathematicians are
. Just like trying to solve a difficult
problem that hasn't been solved for 200 or 300 years, the
stock market is exactly like that. Difficult
problems keep appearing endlessly, and we are the
ones striving to solve them. Sometimes we get them wrong, and sometimes we get them right, but when we get them right, it feels amazing
.
yes.   Right
?  That is correct.  Dopamine is
bursting.
How about Pilban?  Ah, actually,
I woke up at 2 PM yesterday and have been
watching it until now. I think it was
a bit of an overreaction.
So, while
people's sentiment might
worsen ahead of the holidays, I think it might
rebound today due to yesterday's overreaction
.
yes.
So, there is an event taking place to celebrate Independence Day, and the
market, right?
yes.  It won't plummet.
But as I just mentioned, this
is all a seesaw game.  Seesaw game.
Now, regarding the domestic market, uh, the
KOSPI's decline is deepening right now.
What do you think will happen to the KOSPI?   It
has dropped to the 51-day moving average.  It is
breaking out of the city trend and going down. It
started at around 4.46, and
there is a higher possibility of a bearish candle today, as noise regarding the semiconductor sector continues to emerge.   It is
still difficult to gauge whether these various things will materialize or actually affect companies, but since
sentiment seems to be continuously deteriorating, I
think today will see a stronger bearish candle and a higher level of inertia.   In
our country's market, the
morning session
moves by looking at the US market from the opening price, and the afternoon session,
right?  I am watching the US market tonight. Yes, it remains to be seen whether the selling pressure will be absorbed until
around 10 PM and a
rebound will follow,
or if it will just keep falling and close.
The KOSDAQ is showing another bearish candle.
Beekeeping. Yes,
beekeeping.  Ah, it changed to beekeeping.
But the opening price was at 2% earlier
.  yes.   It
dropped from 2.67% to 5% now, so yes, there is a
possibility of a bullish candle with a long lower wick. That is
how it is currently appearing, and I mean, it is
coming out as a bullish candle. Yes, you
know, that excessive gap.
Because of that, the water quality was probably a bit good.
Ah, that
gap?
Yeah, you have to
either get a gap or
sell the dog.  So, since he was
always so great, he was doing this and that, and
his score was pretty
good.   I
was talking about that Hive report earlier, and
Hive is a plus.  It looks like the report is having some effect
.   Uh
, yes.  [Laughs]
Ah, but well, the HYBE
stock price moved so differently from what I expected that it
dropped a lot in advance.
All right.
Hmm. If we
look at that, how are the Bollinger bands set up right
now?  Uh,
how far do you think it will go?
Ah, Jisu?   yes
.
for a moment.   This is just my
personal opinion, really.
Ah, actually, on the weekly chart, I
broke the upper band and came down, but it is very
rare for it to go to the middle band.   If
we look at this trend—the recent trend, that is, the trend over the past year and a half.   hmm.  hmm.
But if it has to drop to the Bollinger Intermediate level and
then to 27,000 points, I do
n't think that's quite right
.  Looking at the daily chart, it could
drop to around 7,500
.
7,500.   yes
It's 7,800 right now.   yes
.   On the
daily chart, the 60-week moving average is currently at
7,400 won.   yes
.
Uh, that is exactly similar to that place.
When Researcher Lee Eun-taek mentioned the divergence last time, it was the divergence relative to the 50-day moving average
.   yes
.  If the 50-day gap exceeds 130%, I'm
careful.  But this time, it couldn't cross the line and
dropped to the
120 mark.   That's right
.  That was the case, but last time, when Jeon Jeong-tae
plummeted, rebounded, and then
fell again to form a double bottom, he
slightly broke the 60-day moving average, gave us a scare, and then came back up, right?
The timing to verify the market is late July. That is why
I decided to follow the top manager
starting August 1st. If
the market shows the kind of pattern seen in early July, a
rebound
buying spree will be forced at a certain level.
Also, considering that the National Pension Service has already
started its rebalancing, the question is: if foreign investors
sell and the National Pension Service sells even more, who will
buy?
However, since individual
investors usually enter the market aggressively when prices fall—with
investor deposits currently around 140 trillion
won and money
mob activity continuing in retirement pension accounts—the further the market
drops, the more attractive the price
becomes.
Once the divergence correction ends,
strong buying pressure is expected to follow. However, as I
mentioned earlier, there is still
some uncertainty regarding the CPI and the prospect of interest rate hikes. Therefore, although
July is traditionally a bull market, it
seems people believe that if volatility fluctuates this time, it will be a somewhat unpredictable market.
yes.  I will end the discussion here for today, July 2nd
.
Thank you to everyone for being with us.  thank you